Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number, and that
number is two one nine two. David P. Here's a
caller who says I was wrong about something.
I think they're wrong. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 6: David, you made a mistake on your
show the other day. You said that rants would,
of course, would go up because everything
else is going up. But I own a house and
my mortgage does not go up just because everything
else is going up. I'm still paying the same amount
for my mortgage. Yeah, I went to go get a
new mortgage. That would be another thing.
But, you know, mortgages don't go up just
because everything else goes up.
Speaker 1: OK, so first of all,
if you have an adjustable rate mortgage,
if rates go up, then your mortgage will
go up. But the caller is confused. The
point I made and that we talked about is
when home prices go up and the way you see home
prices go up as they sell for more. I'm talking
about transactions. When you start seeing houses
and apartment buildings transact for more money.
Those increased sale prices are then reflected
in rents. I know that if you already own a house.
Then the fact that other houses that are being
sold sell for more doesn't affect your mortgage,
but the point was we would expect that when home
sale prices go up and this is the homes that are
being sold, not you just living in your house,
sir. When home for sale, when home prices go up,
then you see rents reflect those increased sale
prices with higher rents. That was the point.
I wasn't wrong. We don't need to issue a
correction. I would be right here issuing
one if I needed to. OK, on the bonus show
today, more Western companies are severing
ties with Russia. We'll tell you which ones.
The Major League Baseball season is already
delayed and we'll talk about the labor dispute
that's going on, and we will talk about primary
results from Texas, where, yes, Beto O'Rourke
won the Democratic gubernatorial primary.
Incumbent Greg Abbott won the Republican
president gubernatorial primary. We'll
talk about what that race is shaping up to be and
much more on two days bonus show. Sign up at Join
Unidentified: Pacman Dot Com
and we will see you that.